my name is ian i run
a consultancy it's about 10 years old
here in the uk um mostly based up in
london um i work on a range of data
science problems got a couple of people
working with me
and one of the problems that i face
running my own consultancy
is the requirement to go into a client's
office and work on a number of projects
in a tight time frame
and iterate on a wide variety of
problems
and often the quick iteration speed that
python gives me is wonderful
until i hit the bottleneck where i want
to process a million of those things
and then it will take overnight to run
and so i spent a lot of time working on
high performance options
so that i can quickly scale up and run
things quickly
so a part of this involves profiling so
doing a lot of profiling to understand
why a system is running slowly and not
thinking in
large engineering heavy terms about
setting up a big profiling framework for
one particular system and keeping an eye
on it
but instead diving in quickly so getting
results in 30 minutes to understand
out of 10 000 lines of code where my
particular bottleneck is and how to
solve it
and that's something i'm going to cover
in this talk because it's something that
engineers often avoid because it's a
little bit of a pain to get set up
and there are some good options and i
think people avoid some of those options
so i'll talk a little bit about that and
then i'm going to look at ways of
speeding up the bottlenecks that are
uncovered
looking at both just in time compilers
so pi pi for example
and pythran and number and also static
compilers particularly siphon and
shed skin and then some of the options
around there and there's a good reason
to
think about the need for speeding up the
bottlenecks in code
both in terms of cpu execution time and
ram usage
and that's because certainly for me if
i've got a problem and it stretches on
more than one machine
all of a sudden the problem doesn't fit
in my head and so i have to start
thinking about cluster management and
maintenance of my
system and in particular reliability of
data
latency issues and all the rest really i
just want to boil a set of data down
into one machine where i can do some
analysis on it
so it's always a quite keen in my mind
to think about the largest data set i
can work with that fits inside
eight gigabytes and four cores and a
couple of hundred
gigs of ssd storage say so it's a
different scale of problems to some of
the problems discussed by other speakers
and other teachers here
and then there's um this final point
about high performance so keeping the
team speed high
just because i can work with say siphon
and
wonderfully exploit a low c level all
the cores on one machine
heavily compiled down with all the
optimizations to make a piece of code
about as fast as it would be if i coded
it in c
if no one else in the team understands
it then the bus factor of this
particular bit of analysis is one
so if i get sick or get knocked over by
a bus then no one can pick this code up
again
and i've seen startups massively
hindered by
having a cto understand how to make a
critical piece of their infrastructure
work as fast as possible and then leave
at which point their startup is dead so
keeping the idea of the velocity of the
team in mind as well as the velocity of
progress with the code
is quite important and that helps to
inform the landscape that we're looking
at
so i'm also working on a book on high
performance python so
the slides here are taken out of the
chapters on profiling
static compilation and uh jits
i've got a mailing list um so we've got
some announces there the rough cut the
first few chapters should be online soon
if you're in o'reilly we tried to go for
uh
speedy snakes as the um the subtitle we
weren't allowed that
i tried to get the uh the image changed
so we could have a wide-eyed snake with
crazy big eyes
and a turbo jets on his back but i riley
don't do cartoons
um and so then we tried to go for
hypersonic herpetology but that's too
latin so we just had to go with
practical performance programming
so show of hands how many of you know
the c profile module
i'm guessing most of you how many of you
know the run snake module
okay i found obviously good um so run
snake is a simple visualizer for
the uh the c profile module um it gives
us this nice box plot where you can see
where the majority of your time is spent
in this case a function
is taken most of the time and then
there's a call to the abs function in
there
that takes a fair chunk of the time
about 25 of that routine's execution
time
what we can't see is what's happening in
the other 75 percent of the execution
time inside that function
and there's no way to drill in with c
profile
it just tells us that the overall
runtime of the function call was not the
individual
python lines inside the code so that's
not so useful but it gives us
it's kind of a blunt tool when you've
got a complex system and you see
many many thin lines and then one large
block in the middle you found your slow
function so it's easy to go and
work on that another downside of
c profile is that you don't get to do
any argument analysis so
if you've got the same function being
called from several different points
you get the cumulative time that the
function is being called
but you can't see which set of arguments
are causing some kind of pathological
behavior
so that one part of your runtime's
execution goes really horrible
and that's a problem that i haven't seen
addressed anywhere in any of the
profilers at the moment
so line profiler from robert kern and
this i think is one of the strongest
profiling tools who here knows line
profiler
okay okay some of you good um so line
profiles is
pretty amazing it's uh written in c it's
a scissor system
i'm not sure it's written in c so it
hooks in to
see python at a low level it does slow
your code down when you're running it
but it does instrument every single line
and so if you come from a visual studio
background you'll be
you'll be used to this kind of thing but
it was a wonderful find when i came
across it in the python world
one of the nice things about it is it
annotates every single one of our lines
of code
the cost is you have to put a decorator
in the top that means you put a
decorator in and then your unit tests
start to fail because the unit tests
don't inject that decorator
so there's a little trade-off between
getting the correctness of your code
working
um versus uh profiling it because if
you're profiling and optimizing and not
running your tests
you could end up spending a day
wonderfully optimizing a function
being really proud of the result and at
the end of the day taking out the app
profile decorator
running a unit test and realizing you've
got a very fast but wrong solution
it's something you don't want to be
doing so one of the nice things
about this is that you get to count the
time cost this is normalized to some
constant that's not shown
the time cost of each of the lines of
execution but what you really care about
is the percentage time spent on the
various lines
so we can see that this inner loop in
this julia set calculation
is the really expensive part and out of
these three lines
um the even the int increment is quite
expensive
uh due to the dynamic nature of python
and this outer loop here one of the
downsides of line profiler and all the
profiling tools
is that we've got a compound statement
we know that this statement is one of
the slowest in the code
but we don't know which part of it is
one of the is which
side of it is the slowest and to deal
with that you have to break it down and
look into it some more as far as i know
there's no way past that
with python tools at the moment but this
is definitely one of the best tools for
profiling uh code for cpu time
that brings us on to the memory profile
this is a relatively new tool who knows
memory profiler okay okay
so this is written a couple of years ago
and memory profiler has basically the
same interface
same decorator the same kind of output
it uses the psutil module so it's
looking
at the process space and talking to the
operating system to get process details
and here we're checking
external memory increments and
decrements for the process
over time so we're not talking to python
we're not asking it how big is that
object
we're saying you've done a line of code
operating system tell me what the
external effect is and so
uh due to caching and due to
over-allocation so we can see quite
large changes in memory usage
but also if you're using c extensions
which don't tell the python interpreter
how big or small their memory usage is
we get to see it because the operating
system tells us what's going on
so in this particular case the memory
output is not so useful here
we get to see that allocating a million
integers of a singular item zero
across seven meg great and if we
build up a number of uh several million
intermediate objects that cost another
32 meg worth of
memory um not so useful in a well in a
smaller case like this
very useful uh if you're just looking in
ipython with a magic so percent
memit you can give percent memoit an
argument and it will tell you what the
process space
uh changed by so seven meg for a
singular object with a million uh
indexes
and and a million different integers
cost a different amount of ram because
you're making a million different
numbers at this point
this is python 27 i'm running this in
yes
i think there's no reason why memory
profiler wouldn't run in python 3.
line profiler i don't know if it's
compatible with bison 3.
something that comes out of memory
profiler is improv
and so here we can look at the dynamic
state of a system over time
so here we're just looking at this is um
some pull requests from the psychic
learn project
so this becomes a visual communication
and discussion tool
and this is a little bit exciting if
you're thinking about
you've spent a day working on something
you really understand the memory
behavior and the cpu behavior you've
really got it in your head
now you've got to convince your boss and
your associated team that it's worth
making this
large set of code changes to improve a
chunk of code how do you describe the
overall behavior of your system over
time
and so here with improv uh
i've taken the labels out there i just
stripped those out but you can see the
brackets
where the labels will be attached
telling us what each of these code
blocks are doing
before a particular change and that's
about three gigs worth of ram being used
here
with lots of cyclic allocations and then
about two gig
after this change has been applied and
actually if you follow that pull request
you'll see that this was the proposed
fix
and then the discussion started at that
point and there was much more discussion
trying to understand the root cause of
the behavior
and the cpu implications as well as the
memory implications
leading to a couple of fixes that came
out of this
so it becomes a nice discussion tool for
communicating in a team
and i think that we can use memory
profiler
as a generalized resource profiler so
i've begun
talking uh to the authors um i've been
playing with
recording rather than using psu tool to
record
memory usage i've been looking in this
case at i o usage so just looking at the
number of bytes sent
in and out of network interfaces so this
is a
single process in serially fetching
documents off the web
so utterly naive case takes 60 seconds
and then 15 seconds with 20 processes or
so gathering in parallel
um i mean this is quite a it's a very
simplistic use of this but we get to see
shorter time more bandwidth being used
and if we run it at full max capacity we
end up
topping out the the network allowance
and so we get to see the external
constraints imposed upon our machine
with this
i've also been looking not just at um io
over the network but
i o from the disk as well that's kind of
interesting when you're doing a lot of
reading and writing of data
beginning to think about contention and
i think we can begin to expand this
just into this more general tool where
we can label our python code and really
understand
what's happening so to close off the
profiling
um we can do cpu memory profiling and
with a little bit of hacking this is
like
five lines of changes in the memory
profiler we can begin to profile disk
reading rights and network read writes
via psu tool we can also look at memory
maps so
shared memory blocks and file handles so
maybe we begin to have an external
debugger looking at pathological
behavior at certain points in a system
when external file handles go crazy big
and instead we can start to label our
code and really understand what's
driving that kind of
behavior and that might be really useful
if we're picking up projects that we
haven't worked on before
and we really want to get an
understanding of this new bit of code
rather than just sitting there studying
it
we can look at network connections and
i'm really interested in the idea of
cache utilization
so i've been using perth perfstat
to look at to get the cpu to tell me
about the cpu cpu performance counters
and one thing it can give you is the
average instructions per
cycle so if you're inefficiently using
the cache you'll have a low
average number of instructions being
executed and if you're using say
nice numpy routines you'll have a high
number of instructions
per cycle being executed um
and if your data set is too large it
won't fit into your level three cache or
level two cache
then you'll end up with a lower average
uh execution speed
because the cpu as francesca was talking
about earlier the cpu has to wait for
the data to be pulled in from ram
over that long slow bus into the cache
and then over the shorter but
quicker bus into the cpu where it can be
used and then shuttle back again
and i think the idea of dynamically
profiling and listing which bits of our
code are using caches effectively
and ineffectively is a pretty important
idea
so i'm going to finish off the profiling
bit there any questions on this
made there for stage directions i mean
that all sounds extremely interesting
is there any i don't know is that like a
project that's in its infancy or is that
gonna go i've written some code it works
fabian said
that's great can you how about we start
a new project and i said what i'm
writing this book how about when i
finished writing the book
and so we've said we'll come back to
this in a few months time when the book
is finished
um i think it's pretty interesting so i
want to push on with it
um certainly i'll push the yeah the
code's not there yet but there's no
reason why the code can't go out and
it's current very hacky state
i've done nothing on the lib perf bit
apart from look at the library
it looks like i can hook in where i want
to hook in and
use this and i use perfstat externally
to run
a python interpreter and then
investigate performance
i don't see why i can't hook it all
together but i haven't done that
okay and so in the book i've got a
little bit on
mocking up a dummy decorator for both
line profiler memory profiler
and i'm hoping that can get included
back into those projects so just so you
can copy paste it or off the man page or
whatever
because there's nothing worse than after
a day optimizing your code then going
back and realizing you've busted your
tests and you're an idiot
okay so moving on to um making the code
go faster
and so um siphon will be the tools
that's uh hands up system i'm guessing
most of you know scython
how many of you used siphon in anger
okay only a couple of you used titan in
anger fair enough um so there's a good
reason why you won't use site in anger
it's great it is the best tool you do
get the best performance out of your
machine it's
hands down i think the best tool uh to
make your code run fast
if it's cpu bound the reason you will
have problem using it is that you have
to go through and annotate your code so
all of the bold bits the annotations
that we've added in
this is the julia example again um so
you have to start writing c
like code so it won't run inside python
anymore you have to compile it and then
import that module and call the module
that means that your agility goes down
so your ability to quickly hack on this
code
or step into it with the normal debug or
anything that all disappears
so it becomes harder to maintain and
experiment with your code
so it's great if you figured out this is
the function i've got this module
i've got a function i take the function
out i've got a set of them maybe in a
separate module
this is exactly what needs to be
optimized and i don't need to change it
then it's completely the right solution
but it's
in competition with python's goal of
being agile and lightweight
and so that makes it a bit more
difficult to justify particularly when
for example you speed up a physicist
code
and then he says great how do i maintain
this and say well
now i've got to teach you c compiling
and then all of a sudden it's a bit
difficult handing it over and leaving it
with somebody else
so that's a bit of a drawback just to
give you an idea here so
this particular bit of code before
adding any annotations
it runs in c python in 12 seconds
adding in these annotations and
compiling it with siphon
brings it down to 19 seconds so that's a
two order of magnitude improvement or 50
times
speed up um and converting it from
python lists into numpy arrays so really
memory efficient arrays
only improves the the speed overall by a
small amount
and that's just because once you've d
and this is a it's a silly
usage of numpy arrays memory efficient
usage but silly usage
if we use numpy arrays here rather than
lists all we're doing is dereferencing
array elements into some primitive types
and then looping 34 million times in
here tightly on some primitive types
so the fact that we had the data stored
in a list or an amp array doesn't really
come to play into this
now siphon i've mentioned that it's the
best way to get the best speed up
it's one of the three tools that hooks
in with openmp
so with openmp you get to use all of the
cores on your cpu
as long as you can get away from the
gill restrictions so you need to step
outside of the global interpreter lock
so if you are working on non-python code
so particularly you've stored your data
in a numpy array which is a large block
of bytes
which can be controlled by the python
interpreter but doesn't have to be
we can then a certain point in the code
use the no gill parallel
context manager to step outside of the
girl we suspend the guild temporarily
and then we use the p range operator in
siphon and that just says give me as
many threads running at a hall by level
um as are available on this machine and
then run in parallel and once we do that
our runtime drops from 0.15 seconds to
0.05 seconds
it's not quite a full four times speed
up on the four core machine i was using
but it's pretty good it's quite a nice
improvement and the reason it's not a
full four times improvement in speed is
because
in this particular case uh the julia
said it's unpredictable how many
iterations are required at each of the
points which is why we get the pretty
plot coming out of it
because it's unpredictable uh the
utilization of the cause isn't as
perfect as it would be in a fully
embarrassingly parallel um equally work
loaded
job
so stepping on to shed skin who knows
shed skin
one two three okay right now we're
working at it so uh
shedskin shedskin is a wonderful project
it's almost known by nobody which is a
real shame
there are some limitations around it
here we're looking at a bit of debug
output
with shedskin you point shedskin at a
module
in that module you've got a little main
routine which calls the function that
you want to compile
shedskin looks at the function looks at
the types in that function looks at the
function you're calling
and performs a full type annotation of
the function so you do no manual labor
at all
it does it all for you it then spits out
some c you run make
it gives you a compiled.so you import
that module it's just a compiled module
so it's just like syson only
you do no work so it's wonderful the
limitation is it doesn't work on numpy
and it doesn't use the bite array
interface
the memory view interface so if you're
using
a large block of ram so you've got a
python array not a numpy rh to python
array
which can expose the bytes hidden behind
it that can't be
used separately by shed skin and what
sheds can done is takes takes the memory
space
in the python world and copies it all to
a fresh copy
so if you've got a gig of ram you end up
with two gigs of ram
shedskin works in the sea world on this
other gig of ram and then passes a
result back
now if you compare the runtime execution
of the on this julius example
uh with siphon and with shedskin you end
up with the same runtime
if you ignore openmp so on the
single-sided version the same runtime
shared skin's a tiny bit slower and
that's because it's copying over a large
amount of
data so it's the memory overhead is the
only thing that's the difference between
the two
so and that's this .02 seconds down here
difference in the runtime
um it has occurred to me and i'm not
quite sure why anyone hasn't played with
this
why can't we just take this fully
annotated output which is this is the
debug output but there's an ast built up
inside shed skin
why can't we take that and just write
out a version that's syphon compatible
it wouldn't necessarily be correct first
time but it will give you a hell of a
hint as to how to get it correct
and so the the time to teach someone
else to start using siphon would go down
massively
and it would open the door to them
moving into the numpy annotations i
think
who knows pythran okay good
so python python's really interesting so
python is a bit like shedskin but it
works with numpy
and it works with openmp so i think it's
the best of
all these worlds right now you do have
to do a tiny bit of work you do a
one-line annotation it's a comment you
put python export
my function and then some types so in
the list example it's
int a complex list and a complex list
and then everything else is exactly as
it was before you do pythran
my module you get a compiled library
coming out at the side
you run it and then it runs 0.4 second
so it's not quite as good as the siphon
output right now but it's pretty good
um i have a geek confession so
i set the scene valentine's night 1am
i was filing a performance bug for this
particular bit of code my wife was out
of the country so i was allowed to sit
there and play
um the reason i mentioned that is that i
filed at 1am
the next morning the authors had come
back for the new table fixing that
performance bug they didn't like the
fact that i'd found anything wrong with
this
um and so it was running up i don't know
0.7 seconds and they got it down to
point four
and they're actively looking at why it's
point four not point two at the moment
so they're
really they're a tiny team they're a
really active team
um so the really interesting bit about
it is the fact that you can pass in it's
a slightly weird syntax you use the
square bracket syntax to pass in
the numpy arrays instead so we have
complex square brackets and in square
brackets for these
eight bytes so doubles and long int
numpy
objects and then if we do
a comment omp parallel 4 and tell it to
use the dynamic scheduler
you can pass any arguments to omp that
you'd normally see in the sea world
and you have a slightly longer compile
string books just
on their man page we end up dropping
down to 0.10.1 second
and so that's using all the four cores
efficiently but the code is not quite as
efficient as systems output yet
but all you had to do was just add these
two one-line definitions
and so i think that's really interesting
there's a lot that's going to come out
of this
i've been playing with pi pi recently so
um
you all know pi five um pi pi on python
2.7 code
basically it just works if you're not
importing external c modules so you're
just staying within the python ecosystem
with regular python coded modules for
example doing django websites or doing
small
cpu bound problems then it's pretty
great it just works there's a tiny
start-up cost
um it's memory usage defies
any heuristics i've gained over the
years they've got some clever
strategies for unboxing when necessary
and otherwise
storing bytes rather than the higher
level python objects until necessary
but at the same time it can use more ram
but
i know of people using this in
production where they've replaced
servers by switching
pi pi away from regular python and so
that that side of things works just
great
um there's little support for hooking
into c extensions so you can't use
regular numpy with pi pi and this is
um a point of interesting discussion in
the community
um for those straddling those worlds um
but things like the multi-processing
module and ipython they work just fine
you just plug them in just install them
they run
and so rather than doing python pip
install you just do pipe i pip install
and then
these things work running my
earlier list version of the code pipe i
ran it in 0.3 seconds so that's great it
runs super quick
there's a numpy branch which is being
re-implemented in pi pi
um it's definitely incomplete at the
moment there are some bugs in there the
team are pretty quick at fixing
those bugs but in my experience so far
the numpy code doesn't run as fast as
regular numpy code it can be a factor of
two or more slower
and so i don't think it's useful right
now it's interesting to experiment with
the fact that there are bugs hidden away
in there i'd strongly suggest that you
have a good unit test suite just to
validate the code that you're running
and so you're really on top of it
when i ran the c python example with uh
the numpy code
so that's not compiling anything this is
using c python
on numpy doing a million d references
into the numpy array
that d reference is really expensive and
so the whole thing takes 50 odd seconds
to run which is horribly slow
and numpy gets it down to five seconds
it's not the same as the 0.2 seconds of
the other examples
i'm not sure why it's slower than the
compiled examples i suspect it's because
numpy is respecting the dynamic nature
of the d references that it's doing
rather than doing the static compilation
all the other options are doing
but i haven't got to the bottom of that
particular difference in speed here if
anyone's got opinions on that please
come and find me later and
inform me last example
number so this is continuums contender
into the
set of just-in-time compilers um
this is also pretty cool we just do a
one-line change game you've got a
decorator
and then number uses the llvm tool chain
to dynamically look at your code during
execution
and then to compile it and optimize it
and
they do have support for openmp it's not
in the i think the current public
release i couldn't find it in there
but i know that p range exists so the
parallel range operator
and they're talking about having support
for the gpu that's because with the llvm
tool chain
you've got a large unified tool chain
and so you can sit
on the back of anyone's work for example
outputting rather than machine code
outputting code that will go off to
opencl
so they've got some gpu support in there
um my runtime here with number just that
one line change was point four seconds
again
it only works off numpy data it won't
work off it won't give you any
improvement with python lists
and so it needs the numpy stuff oh and
there's some
python python3 support a couple of lines
here are commented out
each time i use number the api has
changed a little bit and a few things
have just
changed for whatever reason i couldn't
get abs to be recognized for some reason
but if i expanded the math it worked
just fine
and in the current release due to the
rewrite they're going through you can't
allocate new arrays inside a function
that's being
number jitted um before you could and i
imagine shortly we'll be able to again
and so just be aware that if you're
using number it's still quite dynamic in
its evolution
so coming up to some conclusions so uh
trade-offs well
pi pi there's there's no learning curve
you just use it there are some
use cases of code which works well in
python
um but works poorly um
in c python i believe due to ref
counting you
want to open files in a context manager
rather than
rather than other ways but i forget the
details there's a couple of things that
are documented it's all really obvious
it's all perfectly normal python it's
just idiosyncratic ways of writing code
that works in c
python doesn't work so well with pi pi
but apart from that it all works
shedskin super easy to use you get a big
win because it will just compile down to
c
single threaded i've tried hacking the c
code to get openmp support before and i
failed when i was messing around with it
i'm pretty sure it's possible i'm not
quite sure why i didn't get it working
so it's very easy to use but it only
works if you're working with non-numpy
data
um system so if you're just doing system
on pure python then
it's easy to learn easy to use you get a
great big speed up
and syphon with openmp and numpy
definitely days to learn
so it's hard to get a team to use it and
it's hard to get the general background
knowledge required to debug it say
but if you want the best way to exploit
the
cpus available to you this is definitely
the way to go
number and python a couple of hours to
learn tops
installing number is a pain number
requires llvm
llvm requires a billion other things and
to install
those when i'd spent over half a day on
my
four core i7 laptop sitting there
compiling and failing to get
most of the way through whatever the
process was i gave up and i downloaded
anaconda
and a condom at their distribution that
makes it really easy to use which is
great but then you've got a dependency
on an entire new distribution
so there's a team cost involved there a
deployment cost certainly
which might be too great to bear but for
research code is definitely worth
playing with
python requires a couple of libraries a
modern boost and that's about it
took me 15 minutes to get that installed
um i really think
pythran with the openmp support is
something interesting to watch
if you're doing short projects where you
want to get a quick win
over many cores then definitely you'll
get an easy win there
and i haven't mentioned nomex pro which
is written by francesca was talking
earlier
so numexpro compiles compiles
your numpy arrays and then vectorizes
them intelligently
so it works on uh just in regular python
code
that's a nice easy way to get better
cache performance out of large array
operations
so if you've got large arrays and you're
working with numpy have a look at
bra
david cook i didn't know that okay
okay okay okay well francesca is not the
creator but he is the maintainer
i am nonetheless happy because i've used
it in production and it works very well
david cook okay and so to wrap up
i think we need richer profiling options
the fact that it's not so
rich a world of tools right now means
it's easier to ignore doing it
which means you spend more time
hypothesizing or maybe more times just
ignoring and going with your gut which
is almost certainly the wrong option
so i think we need more profiling tools
um four cores is commonplace 12 cores
that cost a couple of thousand dollars
right now for 12 physical cores
and then you can get sets of
motherboards which will be unified by
unix or linux and presented as one
machine so we have many cores
dealing with the requirements of mini
core computation and locking and sharing
resources is hard
so i really think moving away from hand
annotating code if possible to avoid
that loss of agility
uh and then using jits and any automatic
compiler technique
um given that they give pretty good
results right now out of the box for
almost no effort
i think that's a really interesting
point that we should be considering
because what's that final point that i
make
what the hell did i mean there so yeah
cost cost of cpus
is cheaper than cost of human time so
you don't want to be burning human time
particularly
lowering team velocity you want to keep
your team velocity high and probably
just spin up a few more cpus because
overall that's going to be cheaper for
you
so i think that's uh that's the outcome
of all of this there's some interesting
alternatives
um armin is playing with um software
transactional memory inside pi pi
uh to get rid of locking where you have
to do your own locking and instead it
will deal with
memory changes a bit like transactions
in a database it's a really interesting
idea
um that's i'm not quite sure where
that's going to come and that's not
ready for use right now as far as i can
see
but that's certainly going to change
things when it comes out and as and when
it works
um but in the meantime i'm pretty sure
that's the landscape of what works right
now for high performance calculations
um in python um i'm very happy to talk
to any of you if you're using
pytharon or number in production because
i want to get some more use cases
and otherwise i'm just always happy to
chat about this stuff so thank you very
much
um how much time do i have
okay a couple of questions um
yes it's definitely worth doing
profiling on the compiled code if you
want to understand what's happening in
the compiled code
so and it's a bit difficult
you have another set of tools because
then you're looking at profiling at the
c
code level rather than the python level
um that's something i'm not covering in
the book and i feel a bit remiss by not
doing that but it's a whole nother
layer of pain and understanding to go
through
if you've got experience profiling uh c
code then
sure you should definitely think about
doing that um
some of the tools so uh siphon gives you
an annotation option
with the annotation option you get an
html output showing you
your lines of sight and code colored
from white to yellow
if they're yellow they've got many lines
of calls back into the python library
and if they're white they've got no
calls into the python library it's all
pure c
so the game is to turn all the yellow
lines into white lines where possible
and if you can do that on your innermost
loops although you don't get any
performance figures you just
you pretty pretty quickly you figure out
which yellow lines are important and you
want to get rid of them
normally by moving to numpy if you're
doing numeric calculations
and then you can get rid of most of this
yellow scaffolding and that means that
it's compiling on the c
side with no links back into the python
side so no need to hook up with the gill
and then no need to have slower
performance overall
i have no opinion of cfi i've only ever
heard good things about it but i haven't
played with it myself
so it's something else on my list and
i'd love to have time to play with it
and i haven't got around to it yet but i
genuinely have only heard nice things
about it from people who have used them
so i think it's a good thing
so i've got a a process from going years
back with system where i
um i just tend to use named files in a
set of name directories where i work
through
um i mean i can version control it
instead but by having them all lined up
in different directions i can compare
the html output and then i can marry up
the different amount of yellow
with the runtimes that i'm measuring and
then i can get an intuitive feel as to
how
changing the yellow in this part gives
me a better result
so i yeah i keep a trace of everything
there but it's just a better workflow
david so you're recommending visual
studio as a debugger and
profile at the sea level okay do you
have a linux recommendation
or is it does anyone have a linux
recommendation
google perth tools
yep ah okay so yes you're right so
that's because the author hasn't
implemented the memory view interface
necessary to look at the bytes behind
um look at the bytes that so numpy has a
python level
and behind the scenes it has a c level
which contains all of the data
that's exposed via a couple of
interfaces memory view is one of them
siphon can look at that interface
because code was written specifically to
look at that particular interface so
rather than seeing the high level python
object
it can see the raw bytes behind it and
as long as you stop the global
interpreter lock so you use the nokia
operator
then you can access those bytes and
guarantee that you're not messing these
bytes around in any way that's going to
conflict with the
python runtime with shedskin that hasn't
been implemented
um i don't know why but it hasn't been
there's
some work and it's specialized that's
all i know
all right i better call it there before
any more hard questions turn up
thank you very much